[Music]
all right welcome to every damn day
we're going to talk about some big
Marvel stars getting their own web
series we're going to talk about Bert
and Ernie and ask if they're gay or not
but first watch this video the man
rubbing fruit on his butt
sure produce a Virginia man went to jail
for allegedly robbing grocery store
produce right there on his guys he was
only pretending to put that fruit on his
butt is this okay no no okay
controversial why not this feels like a
prank Jordan would pull oh maybe this
guy's fine I don't know you know his
sentence or like I guess he was charged
with indecent exposure yeah without his
dick he rubbed his covered butthole yeah
that's not indecent again Hannah on the
jury fan tried it's a bummer though he
can't go within 10 miles of a grocery
store for the rest of his life Jordan
worse we're comparing you to this fellow
do you want to defend yourself what
would you say I mean I I did the same
thing I mean roll that video no okay
this is the Comedy Central creators room
oh that orange got deep in the crash
well you know which one that was home
cut out of his shorts where his butthole
is exposed
well you're defending him now exposed no
we're good we do you should be tried
just like this guy should be tried by a
twelve people your jury of your peers
wherever they find 12 boys
yeah well are you gonna call the cops or
what shooting right banana yes I did and
I loved it also everyone is so dramatic
everyone loves eating ass and then you
had fruit to the mix and everyone's so
grossed out I was going to jail for
myung-bak famously loves eating ass in
the area saying that he's all upset
about a but banana ok get with it Ryan
next story moving on I want to talk
about Bert and Ernie so one of the
writers from Sesame Street named Marc
Saltzman recently made news by saying
that he wrote them as if they were gay
he based it on a real-life relationship
he had so then the creator Frank Oz
weighed in he said of course they're not
gay but why that question doesn't really
matter why they need to define people as
only gay there's much more to a human
being than just straightness or gayness
and it created this whole Twitter storm
what do we think of this and in general
of creators of fictional characters kind
of after the fact weighing in on stuff
like this this is
I'm not going to be happy until I see
these puppets I want to see an HBO
limited series where these two puppets
have full-on sex scenes no creative
angles guys I want to see some puppet
penis alright that's a hot take from
Jordan I agree with Frank just like how
do you walk somebody hey like that's not
the way he's supposed to meet people in
general like I don't think it matters I
think he's just trying to say there's
more to the story about a human being
and first of all we talk about Bernie
you know that right yeah but they don't
have genitals but we talk about Bernie I
mean how do we know this
[Laughter]
which one is Burton which one is Ernie a
cure
that's the yellow one so he's the one
that looks like me yeah that's Bert that
looks like a penis yeah Ernie and Bert
what kind of men are you with that looks
like with the plume of pubic hair coming
out of the urethra Oh Bert and Ernie I'm
sorry I didn't know that the
conversation would go this way we better
move on to the next topic so this is a
marvel you know them they've made a
bunch of movies about superheroes they
got a lot of Disney you know them they
made a bunch of movies about singing
animals they got a bunch of money on
Star Wars they own quite a bit they've
got a streaming service coming out in
2019 and it's a part of the rollout to
promote that Marvel characters like Loki
and Scarlet Witch you might know them as
Tom Hiddleston and let's say they're the
big difference from some of the other
spin-offs they've done is that the big
stars are gonna be in this little web
series that they're making it's gonna
cost like twenty-five million dollars
are we excited is this just a heartless
money grab Jordan what do you think I'm
excited this is gonna be great I love
Tom Hiddleston I love Elizabeth Olsen I
love the characters they play a kind of
a brag that you could say both of their
names right away movie about the cult
you should watch it
Oh Marlin Marlene see sometimes hard to
remember things Marcy Meyers
Martha May I will only watch this if we
get all the Olsen's on board
okay particularly want mary-kate Olsen I
want her husband Nicolas Sarkozy all the
villains
we're just smoking cigarettes the whole
time then I will watch that's funny yeah
that sounds great that would be the
slowest Marvel movie which is saying a
lot
Oh give me a break who knew that you'd
be in a
grumpy mood about this oh I'm grumpy
yeah I'm not grumpy Marvel I've never
seen one Marvel movie and frankly that
is my best feature
you haven't seen any of the movies is
just ridiculous I was in and even
Natasha is Watchmen because when we were
on our flight back from Scotland she
watched it and I saw her I watched movie
like came to an end and they were right
the credits rolled I looked back to see
what you thought and Natasha went like
this - no one else just - well if it
comes up maybe I'll talk about it I
don't know I thought it was genuinely
fine do you guys have characters who you
would want their own TV spin-off for I
bet you do I do because I'm asking the
question yeah
I wanna I want all four of the recent
Hulk's to be in a home together - sitcom
home and it's with Edward Norton Eric
Bana Mark Ruffalo and Lou Ferrigno and
they all live in a fun home together
they don't have powers they're just
hanging out you know what I want to see
is the sharee from Black Panther Black
Panther sister that does all the cool I
wanted to see just always sitting it
over but it's never using whatever guys
glove on the home shopping I want to see
all these shows I think this is great
Disney if you're still buying please
call us let's set up a pitch meeting
we're gonna do something different right
now
[Music]
there's Chris Khan from every day I'm
day and I'm here in LA with fans in and
sometimes they in and we're gonna add
people if it's a fad or fraud cheeto
dust makeup is this a fad or fraud she
don't make cheeto dust makeup this
Bronco
that's a fad yeah this is absolutely a
fad
this is a real picture from the real
website that's actually my shade I think
these are licorice straws
I said yeah whoo dissension amongst
friends
I love it I'm not sure exactly what to
do it I don't want to assume anything
all right this is actually a frog really
yeah
okay next Dan bags oh my god it's like a
fanny pack but like with using the fake
dead bellies let's say a fad yeah I'd
say it's a fad I think this one's a fad
this is absolutely a bad this would you
wear that back
sure I mean why ruin it you already know
I mean just wait till you get the real
dad bags tummy I mean they come next
flavor phone cases like fraud this is
unsanitary a gag gift would you have a
debate trying to start a business
yes okay these are called extendo jeans
they're about nine feet long why would
anyone wear them I think fat I'm gonna
say fraud baby this is a bad people you
could buy more line across 500 bucks no
fruit garbage milk aka compost milk okay
that's a fraud fraud fraud bad fat you
wouldn't drink through garbage I
wouldn't I don't think okay it's
definitely a fraud but I think it's a
good business endeavor
hi fella okay just call it the vampire
facial it's when you take blood and you
smear on your face you let it sit for a
little bit do you wash it off
real trend yeah I know that's a fact
absolutely real and this is a real
picture and it's creepy I don't know
where the blood comes from that's the
scary part here real Aegon's it's just a
bad or fraud nah okay these leggings I
hope that's a fried saying those are
kind of higher actually that might be a
fan bingbing last but not least truck
nuts for shoes okay now you have truck
mats on trucks there you can put it
right on your shoe to let people know
you're not around when you walk this is
a fraud thank God I think they're pretty
cool and I want a beer
[Music]
great so I'll take Mulholland to Sunset
and get on the San Diego freeway 405
from my cool outfit and thorough
understanding of road names you might
have confused me for an LA local I've
spent the last week seamlessly
integrating myself into the West Coast
lifestyle and I'm now an expert on all
things Los angular's Haley word which is
how we say it here in large believes LA
is the second most populous city in the
United States the discovery of oil in
the 1890s brought an influx of factory
workers to the area who were quickly
replaced by women and leggings thanks to
the macho boom of 2017 in the 60s Ellie
became known for free love and Manson
murders and is currently known for sex
dust and the impending Logan Paul
murders here's what's currently trending
in Los Angeles water everyone's obsessed
with it because no one has it denim
jackets they're like pants for your arms
bucket hats everyone in Los Angelos is
putting a bucket on their head make
sense what else are they gonna do use
the bucket for water scooters the
government just ruled to allow 21,000
Dhokla scooters to be distributed
throughout the metropolitan area
residents will be able to use the
scooters to access public transportation
to cut down on travel time between
neighborhoods and to outrun the latest
impending wildfire Oh looks like I've
just been discovered by my agent well
I'm off to hang out with models in the
jacuzzi
on top of a limousine in a little faint
jeweler's hoola wig I wonder if someone
did a fan of snap which which of us
would disappear about do it so how do
you feel it is genuinely fine
[Music]